واصلت دوله قطر اسهاماتها لدعم الجهود
الدوليه خاصه في هذه المرحله الحرجه
والحساسه التي يعيشها العالم حيث تمسكنا
بموقفنا الثابت والواضح الذي ينص على
ضروره احترام سياده اوكرانيا او وحده
اراضيها كما ان سجل تصويتنا على العديد من
قرارات الامم المتحده بشان مساله سياده
اوكرانيا يتحدث عن نفسه
ومنذ بدايه الازمه فتحت دوله قطر قنوات
الاتصال مع عدد من الدول التي سعت مبادرت
بالقيام بدور ايجابي في سبيل التوصل الى
حل سلمي لها حيث قام معالي الشيخ محمد بن
عبد الرحمن الثاني رئيس مجلس الوزراء وزير
الخارجيه بزياره لموسكو في مارس عام 2022
لاجراء محادثات مع نظيره مع بدايه انتداء
اندلاع هذه الازمه في هذه الزياره
ادانا معالي رئيس مجلس الوزراء على لساني
دوله قطر
ادان الحرب في اوكرانيا وهو يقف الى جواري
وزير الخارجيه الروسيه انذاك في موقف كان
يبين بوضوح ان قطر وان كانت ستسعى دائما
الى الطريق الدبلوماسي فانها لن تخجل على
ان تتخذ مواقف مبدئيه واضحه فيما يتعلق
بالتطورات الدوليه
اما في يونيو من عام 2022 اجتمع معاليه مع
وزير الخارجيه الروسي على هامش الاجتماع
الوزاريه المشترك بين مجلس التعاون الدولي
الخليج العربيه وروسيا الاتحاديه في
الرياض هذا الاجتماع وما رافقه من
الاجتماعات بين معالي اصحاب المعالي
الوزراء الخارجيه في دول الخليج اكد ان
الموقف الخليجي في حينه كان ايضا مهما
صياغته على مستوى جماعي وليس على مستوى
فردي وهذا ما تاتى في الرياض عبر وجود
وزير الخارجيه الروسي وعبر مشاركه
الاوكرانيين في الاجتماعي التاليه ولا
يغيب ان نذكر طبعا اللقاء الذي جمع حضرت
صاحب السمو الشيخ تميم بن حمد ال ثاني
امير البلادي المفدى في اكتوبر من عام
بالرئيس الروسي بوتين ذلك على هامش انعقاد
القمه السادسه لمؤتمر التفاعل واجراءات
بناء الثقه في اسيا في استانا عاصمه
جمهوريه كازاخستان
هذه اللقاءات بلا شك اكدت على ان الجهد
القطري يظل مستمرا في تقريب وجهات النظر
وفي محاوله معالجه جوانب هذه الازمه
المختلفه وعلى راسها الجانب الانساني
وتوالت الاتصالات بين المسؤولين القطريين
ومسؤولين في مختلف الدول الاوروبيه
واوكرانيا وروسيا وفي كل هذه الاتصالات
كانت تركيز على اهميه الوصول الى حل سلمي
وعلى تجنيب شعوب العالم اهميه تجنيب شعوب
العالم اي تداعيات لهذه الازمه وعلى راسها
ما يرتبط بالامن الغذائي